this episode is sponsored by endl an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to
help you focus relax and sleep the first
hundred people to click our description
link will get a one week free trial
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
james our master of microscopes is not a
farmer
he is to put it simply fascinated by
microbes and that may lead him to
strange places and cause him to grow
tanks full of weird things but he is not
a farmer
so why
did james master of microscopes that he
is decide to put a sweet potato in a
tank
well i guess you could say he was trying
to rescue it
this poor neglected sweet potato had
reached the point of inedibility with
sprouts growing all over it so it seemed
right to give the sweet potato some
space of its own and let it live a
little for james the inevitable
conclusion was to put the sweet potato
into a tank and here it is thriving as
its sprouts grow tall and its roots
buried deep there are times when james
can even spot the sprouts trying to
escape the seal on a tank maybe he would
just let them burst out but the tank is
currently full of mosquitoes so for now
it stays sealed
the mosquitoes are a story for another
day today we are here for the sweet
potato because it has a very important
job one that it probably never
anticipated having
this sweet potato is going to be a
stand-in for one of the most important
chemical and biological processes in our
world
nitrogen fixation
let's start by taking a tour of the
sweet potatoes roots
imagine that instead of the tank of
water that they're buried in that you
are instead watching the roots from
where they would usually be buried in
the soil
you might see a scene like this a crowd
of countless bacteria traveling toward
the root and away from it some are
shaped like tiny rods and others are
spherical and some form filaments that
trail off like threads
as you look around the root you can see
these bacteria latch onto the root
almost as if they are part of the
plant's own texture and along the root
you might find organisms like this
nostoc a cyanobacteria that can even be
found on plants like cycads that have
above ground roots the clinginess of
nostok is important to plants and
actually to all of us because they
can do
nitrogen fixation
what is that well it's a concept that
comes up often on our channel we talk
about microbes that have an outsized
impact on our world through their role
in translating atmospheric nitrogen into
chemical forms that plants can actually
use but we've never really dived into
what that means and why it is so
important
it all comes down to the fact that
nitrogen is both essential and abundant
and yet difficult to get
when we think of the chemistry of life
and of humans and our planet's
atmosphere our attention often gets
focused on oxygen and carbon dioxide but
nitrogen is the majority of our
atmosphere and it is extremely important
nitrogen is essential to making amino
acids and nucleic acids and those are
important things so if all of the
nitrogen in the world were to disappear
in an instant we would not have protein
we would not have dna we wouldn't have
the fundamental building blocks that
make life on this earth possible which
for the record i think would be bad and
this is true for all life this is
something that we have in common with
the sweet potato we all need nitrogen
fortunately as i said before nitrogen is
abundant around 78 of our atmosphere is
made of nitrogen gas so we should be
good right
[Music]
well no the problem is that nitrogen gas
is diatomic nitrogen two atoms of
nitrogen bonded together and that's just
far too stable it's hard for our bodies
to break the bonds between those
nitrogens and convert them into forms we
need which is why we need to eat other
animals and plants that have nitrogen
but plants have the same problem as us
they can't turn all that nitrogen in the
atmosphere into forms that they can use
but unlike us
plants have a secret weapon
the things that we have been watching
throughout this video
microbes
these microbes these nitrogen fixing
microbes are special because they have
an enzyme called nitrogenase this enzyme
catalyzes the breakup of that strong
bond holding nitrogen gas together
freeing up the nitrogens to become
ingredients in more accessible chemicals
like ammonia
there's one catch though nitrogenase
stops working completely when it is
exposed to oxygen so nitrogen-fixing
organisms have a few options for how to
live
many of them live in anaerobic
conditions where the lack of oxygen
means their vital enzyme will be safe
and other organisms like the
cyanobacteria we've been looking at
create their own internal forms of
protection sequestering the nitrogenase
into special cells called heterocysts
you can actually see the heterocysts
standing out like special green beads on
this dilocospermum which is a kind of
cyanobacteria they're super obvious
rounder and larger than the other cells
within the cyanobacteria filament and
they look so different because they need
thick walls so that oxygen can't pass
through which allows the nitrogenase to
do its thing but these nitrogen fixing
microbes don't keep the nitrogen for
themselves bound to the roots of plants
they give some of what they have made in
exchange for other nutrients that the
plants have made
nitrogen fixation isn't the only way
that plants get their nitrogen there's
also fertilizer the death and decay of
other living organisms and even
lightning which can shatter the bonds of
atmospheric nitrogen and set up its
conversion into other forms
like any other element nitrogen's
journey through our ecosystems takes
many twists and turns setting up
delicate balances and potentially dire
consequences too little nitrogen and
life can't happen
too much and you can choke off lakes as
the thriving plants and algae eventually
reach the limits of what their ecosystem
can support it is this interplay of
nitrogen among so many other elements
that births kills and sustains it
travels through our atmosphere our soils
our lakes our bodies and ends up
sometimes at the root of a strange
rescued sweet potato sprouting in a
mosquito-filled tank
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you again to endl for
sponsoring this episode endl is an app
that takes everything we know about
sound and combines it with technology
and creates personalized soundscapes to
help you focus relax and sleep their app
was named the apple watch app of the
year in 2020 and they have a brand new
soundscape called wind down that they've
made in collaboration with james blake
the goal of wind down is to help you
transition from an active day to a
calmer state so it's great just before
bed too
sound has a direct impact on your
physical and mental well-being and by
adapting in real time to things like
your location weather and even heart
rate endl creates simple pleasant sounds
that can help to calm your mind if
you're interested in trying out endle
just be one of the first 100 people to
download it using the link in our
description and you will get a free week
of audio experiences
thank you so much to all of the people
on screen right now they are our patrons
on patreon and they are the reason that
we are able to make journey to the micro
cosmos the reason that we are able to
put a sweet potato into a tank full of
mosquitoes and the reason that later you
will find out what those mosquitoes are
all about
if you want to become one of those
people check out patreon.com
journey to micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram or tick
tock and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you